[MUSIC PLAY]
RAMZI RIZK: The four of us who
the company was founded, is essentially a photographer.
And when we met in 2010,
was the first thing we did,
to initiate a photography competition.
This was the world's first mobile photography exhibition,
and we realized we had something bite
which is much bigger than we thought.
And it became clear that there
potential was to build a company.
EyeEm is essentially a community.
It's a photographer community.
This is a way for you to take photos, process them,
share them and get lots of feedback.
You can learn.
You can become a better photographer.
It also has quite a wide range of discovery features
which in one way or another lets you discover people and people
on the kind of photos you take and the kind of interests
what you have.
It's about the beauty of photography.
It's about photography in its purest form.
MATIAS CASTELLO: Design is a big, big part of what we do.
And the photos are not created by us.
So what we are trying to build and design,
is a canvas for any photo to look at its best.
We've made several changes to make our program easier,
to simplify the experience.
And it definitely adds to our interaction metric.
The most visible one is probably the menu.
We have removed several items from the navigation
to make it clearer what EyeEm is about.
Now you have access to the three main parts of the program, which
our Discover stream is to discover new content
and content published around you;
your friends stream is where you are
Find all the photos of your friends and the photographers you
follow; and Missions are photo competitions where people
post photos on a particular topic, and then win prizes, and
published.
They are now increasing between 50% and 80% more
Friends and Discover in as before.
And Missions saw an increase of more than 100% in access.
We also saw an increase in people participating
to Missions thanks to the way we restructured the data.
One of the other additions we made to the Android app
to make photographers' lives easier,
is to improve the Camera button and interact with it.
You can tap on the Camera button.
It will fetch your most recent pictures,
No matter where they come from.
And you also have the option to use or access your camera
to get to the whole gallery.
By doing all this a single act,
We saw a 73% increase in people entering our camera.
We also saw increments throughout people watching photos
edit with EyeEm and also upload photos.
To design different screen sizes and different resolutions
is not as difficult as people usually pretend.
The Android guidelines help you navigate through the different
formats - whether it's phones or tablets, portrait
or landscape - and definitely acts as a guide,
and help you customize your design and the
feature sets that you have for different screen sizes.
We think it's important to follow Android design guidelines,
since that's what people expect when
they are on the Android platform.
It is important to keep those patterns in mind
and also to put them first, because it is
the easiest way for people to know how to use your program.
RAMZI RIZK: What started out as a renovation, we basically have
the whole program is stripped off.
And this has led to a much more photo-centric experience,
a much more simplified experience,
a much faster experience.
We've seen extensive interaction, and retention,
and use throughout every single metric
what we have.
[MUSIC PLAY]